It's time for us to go to bed now.
Oh! Why do I have to go to bed now?
To go to sleep, of course.
But why do I have to go to sleep?
You don't really do anything when you're asleep, do you?
You do, actually.
And sleeping is important for everybody.
Why is it important to sleep?
Well, for a few reasons.
When you're asleep, your brain helps to sort out different things you've been doing;...
...thinking and learning during the day.
My brain does all of that when I'm asleep?
Yes, it does!
And you do even more things than that when you're asleep.
What else do I do?
Well, your body gets tired during the day,...
...and it needs time to slow down and have a rest,...
...so that you'll be ready for the next day.
Even your breathing slows down and has to rest while you're sleeping.
Oh! But what if I don't feel tired?
Do I still need to go to sleep then?
Oh yes! All people, and especially children, need to go to sleep every night.
And what would happen if I stay there all night tonight?
All night the next night, all night the next night, and all night!
Well, you will get too tired to play, too tired to learn new things, you might get sick,...
...and you would certainly get cross and cranky.
So, even if I'm not tired now, I'd better go to sleep.
Yes, you better.
Then your body will have enough energy for tomorrow,...
...for thinking, playing, laughing, eating, running and growing.
Well, let's go then.
Race you to the bedroom!
Beat you!
Good night!